the idea of pre-college got a lot of
attention during the 2016 election now
it sounds pretty progressive but well
many people don't know is that students
from rich families are the ones who
stand to benefit the most consider what
happened to an Oregon passed a free
Community College program the average
course student got just six hundred
dollars out of the program but the
average rich student got nearly twenty
five hundred dollars that's right rich
students got four times as much money as
poor students at free Community College
now the reason for this is that we
already have lots of programs to help
lower-income students afford College
for instance the Pell Grant program
gives students from poor families up to
fifty eight hundred dollars to help them
pay for college that's enough to pay
tuition and then some at many community
colleges that means poor students pay
much less tuition than rich students
once you factor in financial aid it's no
surprise that when you get rid of
tuition which students are the big
winners don't you think we could spend
that money better somewhere else to
learn more about my take on free College
check out the links in the description
below also let us know what other topics
you want a EEI scholars to cover in 60
seconds